alors que la saison des festivals bat
son plein et à deux semaines des
vacances de la construction
le québec entre dans la septième vague
de la pandémie on n'aime pas
l'augmentation des cas mais il est
encore sous contrôle mais ce qui est
important c'est de rester vigilants dans
les deux dernières semaines le nombre de
cas a bondi de 69 pour ça on compte plus
de 1500 personnes hospitalisées aux
prises avec l'aco vide dont 43 aux soins
intensifs et 1300 travailleurs de la
santé sont absents du réseau malgré tout
québec refuse de réinstaurer des mesures
sanitaires comme le port du masque dans
les transports en commun on ait pu rendu
à obliger des choses alors que les gens
sont très bien des risques il s'est
juste de les rappeler et c'est ça qu'on
fait aujourd'hui je pense que les choses
sont quand même relativement sous
contrôle et imposé des mesures beaucoup
plus sévère ça va ça va amener aussi une
démotivation qu'une perte de confiance
dans la rue il y à peu d'appétit pour
retour à des mesures obligatoires
moi j'ai compris que c'était les vraies
je trouve ça une bonne chose aussi qu'en
soient les de le porter comme voyez dans
les transports en commun j'aimerais
mieux que ce soit comme une
responsabilité individuelle au réduire
la propagation québec tient à rappeler
les règles d'isolement pour ceux qui
contractent de l'aco vide dès
l'apparition des symptômes
ils doivent rester à la maison pendant
cinq jours puis sortir de chez eux
uniquement si c'est essentiel pendant
les cinq jours suivants en portant le
masque on ne devrait pas aller au resto
à et rencontrer des est mis à penser ces
deux ans à distance on ne devrait pas
aller dans des spectacles le
gouvernement lance aussi un nouvel appel
à la vaccination
on le sait qu'après cinq simon ainsi
mobinil la baisse de l'immunité le c'est
comme ça un arbre décisionnel a été
publié par le ministère de la santé pour
comprendre qu'à obtenir une dose de
rappel on encourage particulièrement les
60 ans et plus à le faire dès maintenant
prenez pas de chance aller chercher une
dose de rappel ça fait plus trop en mots
vous avez la dernière dose où vous avez
eu la colline même si la septième vague
s'amorce en ce moment québec s'attend à
une remontée des cas cet automne avec le
retour à l'école et les rassemblements
qui se feront davantage à l'intérieur
plutôt qu'à l'extérieur ici olivier
machin radio canada montréal